find the volume of a tank whose base has
an area of 3x squared plus 30x plus 5
square feet and whose height is 8x minus
5. so let me draw a potential tank here
maybe it's a cylinder so let me draw a
cylindrical tank here
just like that
just like that it's supposed to be a
cylinder and maybe if it was transparent
you would see this back side over there
and these two are the same these are
supposed to be straight lines and the
volume of a let me just label it first
so the area of the base which is the
same as the area of the top here or the
base here
the area of that is three x squared plus
thirty x plus five and they tell us the
height is 8x minus 5.
the height of this
of this tank is 8x minus 5.
the height is
8x minus 5. and if you want to find the
volume
of a of a three-dimensional object like
this you just multiply the area of the
base times the height so the volume is
going to be the area of the base
which is
three x squared plus thirty
x plus 5
times the height times 8x minus 5
times 8x minus 5. now to multiply
something like this out when you have
you know it might seem really
complicated but we once again we just
have to do the distributive property if
you viewed this big thing in pink here
it's just a number if this was like i
don't know the number seven you just say
well this is going to be 7 times 8x
minus 7 times 5 or minus 5 times 7 you
would just distribute it out you just
multiply this entire thing times each of
the terms that's what the distributive
property tells us when you first learned
it so let's do that so it's going to be
this entire thing times 8x or we could
view it as 8x times this entire thing so
8x
times
this entire thing
three x squared
three
x squared plus thirty x plus five
minus five
minus 5 times the entire thing again or
the entire thing times minus 5.
so once again you get 3 x squared plus
30x
plus 5.
and now we just multiply these out we
just distribute out the 8x over this
whole thing and we distribute out the
negative 5 over that old thing so then
we get 8x times 3x squared is
24x to the third power
8x times 30x is what this 240x squared
so plus
240x squared 8x times 5 is plus
40x
and then we multiply this negative 5 out
negative 5 times 3x squared is
negative
negative 15
x squared negative 5 times 30x is
negative 150x
and then negative 5 times 5 is
negative 5 times 5 is negative 25
negative 25 and then we just have to
simplify it from here so we only have
one third degree term one thing that has
an x to the third in it we have this
term right here so we'll write that as
24 x to the third and then what are x
squared terms we have 240 x squared
minus 15 x squared so what's 240 minus
15. it's 225 x squared so plus
225 x squared that's
adding that term to that term right over
there and then we have
and then we have 40x
minus 150
that would be negative 110x
negative 110x and then finally we have
just this negative 25 out here we have
this negative 25 out there that's the
only constant term
and we're done we found the volume of
the tank it's it's given by this by this
polynomial expression right here so this
right here is the volume
the volume of the tank it's equal to 24
x to the third plus 225 x squared minus
110x minus 25.